[Music]
you
evening I'm Stuart brand from the long
now foundation it was pretty good for a
rainy night thank you for coming
as usual when we're here at the collar
there'll be a reception afterwards half
a block down at the long now Museum
office and shop
and Alexander reminds me to remind you
that this Tuesday February 17th
despite Congress a large amount of
analog TV will disappear from the air
forever and there'll be a gathering to
commemorate that or to hear from Bruce
Sterling and from Paul Sappho about what
analog TV is meant and what the shift to
digital means and generally have a week
that'll be at the Berkeley Art Museum
what time Alexander 7 Tuesday night
February 17th when civilizations
collapse analog TV is all it's the first
thing to go and we scheduled this talk
about nine months ago and it seemed to
look kind of a reach then you know
climate change crisis we call it now and
not financial stuff which Dimitri says
it's just the first stage we had Jared
Diamond here a couple years ago saying
in the fullness of time which long now
is about civilizations and society saw
his collapse they collapsed for
different reasons and one gets
interested in that and what do they do
after they collapse one gets interested
in that and so it is very much a long
now topic to have an expert on collapse
Dmitri or loss
thank you very much Stuart good evening
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
showing up it's certainly nice to travel
all the way across the North American
continent and have a few people come to
see you
even if the occasion isn't a happy one
you're here to listen to me talk about
social collapse and the various ways we
can avoid screwing that up along with
everything else that's gone wrong I know
it's a lot to ask of you because why
wouldn't you instead want to go and eat
and drink and be merry well perhaps
there will still be time left for that
after my talk I would like to thank the
long now foundation for inviting me and
I feel very honored to appear in the
same venue as many serious professional
people such as Michael Pollan who will
be here in May or some of the previous
speakers such as Nassim Taleb or Brian
you know some of my favorite people
really I'm just a tourist I flew over
here to give this talk and to take in
the sights and then I'll fly back to
Boston and go back to my day job well
I'm also a blogger and I wrote a book
but then everyone has a book or so it
would seem you might ask yourself then
why on earth did I get invited to speak
here tonight it seems that I'm enjoying
my moment in the limelight because I'm
one of the very few people who several
years ago unequivocally predicted the
demise of the United States as a global
superpower the idea that the USA will go
the way of the USSR seemed preposterous
at the time it doesn't seem so
preposterous anymore
I take it that some of you are still
hedging your bets how is that hedge fund
doing by the way
I think I prefer remaining a tourist
because I have learned from experience
luckily from other people's experience
that being a superpower collapse
predictor is not a good career choice I
learned that by observing what happens
to people who successfully predicted the
collapse of the USSR do you know who and
rayann Alaric is see my point exactly he
successfully predicted the collapse of
the USSR he was off by just half a
decade that was another valuable lesson
for me which is why I will not give you
an exact date when the USA will turn the
into the F USA f is for former
but even if someone could choreograph
the whole event it still wouldn't make
much of a career because once it all
starts falling apart people have far
more important things to attend to than
marveling at the wonderful predictive
abilities of some cassandra like person
I hope that I have made it clear that
I'm not here in any sort of professional
capacity
I consider what I'm doing a kind of
community service so if you don't like
my talk don't worry about me there are
plenty of other things I can do but I
would like my insights to be of help
during these difficult and confusing
times for altruistic reasons mostly
although not entirely this is because
when times get really bad as they did
when the Soviet Union collapsed a lot of
people just completely lose it men
especially successful middle-aged men
breadwinners bastions of society turn
out to be especially vulnerable and when
they just completely lose it they become
very tedious company my hope is that
some amount of preparation psychological
and otherwise can make them a lot less
fragile and a bit more useful and
generally less of a burden women seem
far more able to cope perhaps it is
because they have less of their ego
invested in the whole dubious enterprise
or perhaps their sense of personal
responsibility is tied to those around
them and not some nebulous grand thing
in any case the women always seem far
more able to just put on their gardening
gloves and go do something useful while
the men tend to sit around groaning
about the Empire or the Republic or
whatever it is they lost and when they
do that they become very tedious company
and so without a bit of mental
preparation the men are all liable to
end up very lonely and very drunk so
that's my little intervention
if there is one thing I would like to
claim as my own it is the comparative
theory of superpower collapse for now it
remains just a theory although it is
currently being quite thoroughly tested
the theory states that the United States
and the Soviet Union will have collapsed
for roughly the same reasons namely a
severe and chronic shortfall in the
production of crude oil that magic
addictive elixir of industrial economies
a severe and worsening trade deficit a
runaway military budget and ballooning
foreign debt I call this particular list
of ingredients the super superpower
collapse soup other factors such as the
inability to provide an acceptable
quality of life for its citizens or a
systemically corrupt political system
and capable of reform are certainly not
helpful but they do not automatically
lead to collapse because they do not put
the country on a collision course with
reality please don't be concerned though
because as I mentioned this is just a
theory
my theory I've been working on this
theory since about 1995 when it occurred
to me that the u.s. is retracing the
same trajectory as the USSR as so often
as the case having this realization was
largely a matter of being in the right
place at the right time the two most
important methods of solving problems
are one by knowing the solution ahead of
time and to guessing it correctly I
learned this in engineering school from
a certain professor I'm not that good at
guesswork but I do sometimes know the
answer ahead of time I was very well
positioned to have this realization
because I grew up straddling the two
worlds the USSR and the u.s. I grew up
in Russia and moved to the US when I was
12 and so I'm fluent in Russian and I
understand Russian history and Russian
culture the way only a Russian native
can but I also went through high school
and university in the u.s. I had careers
in several industries here I traveled
widely around the country and so I also
have a very good understanding of the US
with all its quirks and idiosyncrasies I
traveled back to Russia in 1989 when
things seemed still seemed pretty more
pretty much with in line with the Soviet
norm and again in 1990 when the economy
was at a standstill and big changes were
clearly on the way I went back there
three more times in the 1990s and
observed the various stages of Soviet
collapse firsthand by mid 1990s I
started to see the Soviet American
superpower dome as a sort of disease
that strives for world dominance but in
a fact eviscerates its host country
eventually leaving behind an empty shell
an impoverished population an economy in
ruins a legacy of social problems and a
tremendous burden of debt the symmetries
between the two global superpowers were
then already too numerous to mention and
they have been growing more obvious ever
since the superpower symmetries may be
of interest to policy wonks and history
buffs and various skeptics but they tell
us nothing that would be useful in our
daily lives it is the asymmetries the
differences between the two superpowers
that I believe to be the most
instructive when the Soviet system went
away many people lost their jobs
everyone lost their savings wages and
pensions were held back for months their
value was wiped out by hyperinflation
there were shortages of food gasoline
medicine consumer goods there was a
large increase in crime and violence and
yet Russian society did not collapse
somehow the Russians found ways to
muddle through how was that possible it
turns out that many aspects of the
Soviet system were paradoxically
resilient in the face of system-wide
collapse many institutions continued to
function and the living arrangement was
such that people did not lose access to
food shelter or transportation and could
survive even without an income the
Soviet economic system failed to thrive
and the Communist experiment at
constructing a worker's paradise on
earth was in the end a failure but as a
side effect it inadvertently achieved a
high level of collapse preparedness
in comparison the American system could
produce significantly better results for
a time but at the cost of creating and
perpetuating a living arrangement that
is very fragile and not at all capable
of holding together through the
inevitable crash even after the Soviet
economy evaporated and the government
largely shut down Russians still had
plenty for them to work with and so
there is a wealth of useful information
and insight that we can extract from the
Russian experience which we can we can
then turn around and put to good use in
helping us improvise a new living
arrangement here in the United States
one that is more likely to be survivable
the mid-1990s did not seem to me as the
right time to voice such ideas the
United States was celebrating its
so-called Cold War war victory getting
over its Vietnam syndrome by bombing
Iraq back to the Stone Age and the
foreign policy wonks coined the term
hyper power and were jabbering on about
full spectrum dominance all sorts of
silly things were happening
professor Fukuyama told us that history
had ended and so we were building a
brave new world where the Chinese made
things out of plastic for us the Indians
provided customer support when these
Chinese made things broke and we paid
for all just by flipping houses
pretending that they were worth a lot of
money whereas they're really just
useless bits of ticky-tacky Alan
Greenspan chided us about irrational
exuberance while consistently
low-balling interest rates
it was the Goldilocks economy not too
hot not too cold remember that and now
it turns out that it was actually more
of a tinkerbell economy because the last
five or so years of economic growth was
more or less a hallucination based on
various debt pyramids the whole house of
cards as President Bush once referred to
it during one of his lucid moments
and now we can look back on all of that
with a funny queasy feeling or we can
look forward and feel nothing but
vertigo while all of these silly things
were going on I thought it best to keep
my comparative theory of super super
power collapsed to myself during that
time I was watching the action in the
oil industry because I understood that
oil imports are the Achilles heel of the
US economy in the mid 1990s oh the
all-time peak in global oil production
was scheduled for the turn of the
century but then a lot of things
happened that delayed it by at least
half a decade perhaps you've noticed
this too there is a certain refrain here
people who try to predict big historical
shifts always turn to be turn out to be
off by about half a decade unsuccessful
predictions on the other hand are always
spot-on as far as timing the world as we
know it failed to end precisely at
midnight on January first year 2000
perhaps there's a physical principle
involved information spreads at the
speed of light while ignorant is
instantaneous at all points in the known
universe
so please make a mental note whenever it
seems to you that I'm making a specific
prediction as to when I think something
is likely to happen just silently add
plus or minus half a decade in any case
about half a decade ago I finally
thought that the time was ripe and as it
turned out I wasn't too far off in June
of 2005 I published an article on the
subject titled post-soviet lessons for a
post American century which was quite
popular even to the extent that I got
paid for it it is available at various
places on the internet a little while
later I formalized my thinking somewhat
into the collapse gap concept which I
presented at a conference in Manhattan
in April of 2006 the slide show from
that presentation titled closing the
collapse gap was posted on the internet
and has been downloaded a few million
times since then then in January of 2008
when it became apparent to me that
financial collapse was well underway and
that other stages of collapse were to
follow I published a short article
titled the five stages of collapse which
I later expanded into a talk I gave at a
conference in Michigan in October of
2008 finally at the end of 2008 I
announced on my blog that I'm getting
out of the prognosticating business I
made enough predictions and they all
seem to be very well on track if I take
half a decade please remember that
collapse is well underway and now I'm
just an observer but this talk is about
something else something other than
making dire predictions and then acting
all smug when they come true you see
there is nothing more useless than
predictions once they have come true
it's like looking at last year's
amazingly successful stock picks what
are you going to do about them this year
what we need are examples of things that
that have been shown to work in the
strange unfamiliar post collapse
environment that were all likely to have
to confront Stuart brand proposed the
title for the talk social collapse best
practices and I thought it was an
excellent idea although the term
practices has been diluted over time to
mean little more than good ideas
initially it stood for the process of
abstracting useful techniques from
examples of what has worked in the past
and applying them to new situations in
order to control risk to increase the
chances of securing a positive outcome
it's a way of skipping a lot of trial
and error and deliberation and
experimentation and to just go with what
works in organizations especially large
organizations best practices also offers
a good way to avoid painful episodes of
watching colleagues trying to think out
of the box whenever they're confronted
with a new problem if your colleagues
were any good at thinking outside the
box they probably wouldn't feel so
compelled their entire working lives
sitting in a box keeping an office chair
warm if there were any good at thinking
outside the box they would have by now
thought of a way to escape from that box
so perhaps what would make them feel
happy and productive again is if someone
came along and gave them a different box
in which in which to think you know a
box better suited to the post collapse
environment here's a key inside you
might think that when collapse happens
nothing works
that's just not the case the old ways of
doing things don't work anymore the old
assumptions are all invalidated consent
conventional goals and measures of
success become irrelevant but a
different set of goals techniques and
measures of success can be brought to
bear immediately and the sooner the
better but enough generalities let's go
through some specifics we'll start with
some generalities and you as you'll see
it will all become very very specific
rather quickly
here's another key insight there are
very few things that are positives or
negatives per se just about everything
is a matter of context now it just so
happens that most things that are
positive spry err to collapse turn out
to be negatives once collapse occurs and
vice versa
for instance prior to collapse having
high in
taury in a business is bad because the
business has the businesses have to
store it and finance it so that they try
to have just-in-time inventory after
collapse high inventory turns out to be
very useful because they can barter it
for the things they need and they can't
easily get more because they don't have
any credit prior to collapse it's good
for a business to have the right level
of staffing and an efficient
organization after collapse what you
want is a gigantic sluggish bureaucracy
that can't unwind operations or lay
people off fast enough through sheer
bureaucratic foot-dragging
prior to collapse what you want is an
effective retail segment and good
customer service after collapse you
regret not having an unreliable retail
segment with shortages and long bread
lines because then people would have
been forced to learn to shift for
themselves instead of standing around
waiting for somebody to come and feed
them if you notice none of the things I
mentioned have any bearing on what is
commonly understood as economic health
prior to collapse the overall
macroeconomic positive is an expanding
economy after collapse economic
contraction is a given and the overall
macroeconomic positive becomes something
of an imponderable so we're forced to
listen to a lot of nonsense the
situation is either slightly better than
expected or slightly worse than expected
we're always either months or years from
economic recovery business as usual will
resume sooner or later because some
television bobblehead said so but let's
take it apart starting from the very
general what are the current
macroeconomic objectives if you listen
to the hot air coming out of Washington
at the moment first growth of course get
the economy going we learned nothing
from the last huge spike in commodity
prices so let's just try again that
calls for economic stimulus aka printing
money let's see how high the prices go
this time maybe this time we will
achieve hyperinflation
second stabilizing financial
institutions getting bought banks
lending that's important to you see
we're just not in enough debt yet that's
our problem we need more debt and
quickly third jobs we need to create
jobs low wage jobs of course to replace
all the high wage manufacturing jobs
that we've been shedding for decades now
and replacing them with low-wage service
sector jobs mainly once without any job
security or benefits right now a lot of
people could slow down the rate at which
they're sinking further into debt if
they quit their jobs that is their job
is a net loss for them as individuals as
well as for the economy as a whole but
of course we need much more of that and
quickly so that's where we are now the
ship is on the rocks water is rising and
the captain is shouting full steam ahead
we're sailing to Afghanistan do you
listen to Ahab up on the bridge or do
you desert your post in the engine room
and go help deploy the lifeboats if you
thought the previous episode of
uncontrolled depth debt expansion
globalized Ponzi schemes and economic
hollowing out with silly then I predict
that you will find the next episode of
feckless grasping at macroeconomics
draws even sillier except that it won't
be funny
what is crashing now is our life-support
system all the systems and institutions
that are keeping us alive and so I don't
recommend passively standing around and
watching the show unless you happen to
have a death wish
right now the Washington economic
stimulus team is putting on their scuba
gear and diving down to the engine room
to try to invent a way to get a diesel
engine to run on seawater they spoke of
change but in reality they're terrified
of change and want to cling with all
their might to the status quo
but this game will soon be over and they
don't have any idea what to do next
so what is there for them to do forget
growth forget jobs forget financial
stability
what should their realistic new
objectives be well here they are
food shelter transportation and security
their task is to find a way to provide
all of these necessities on an emergency
basis in absence of a functioning
economy with Commerce at a standstill
with little or no access to imports and
to make them available to a population
that is largely penniless
if successful society will remain
largely intact and will be able to begin
a slow and painful process of cultural
transformation and eventually develop a
new economy a gradually D
industrializing economy at a much lower
level of resource expenditure
characterized by quite a lot of
austerity and even poverty but in
conditions that are safe decent and
dignified if unsuccessful society will
be gradually destroyed in a series of
convulsions that will leave a defunct
nation composed of many wretched little
fiefdom
given its largely depleted resource base
a dysfunctional collapsing
infrastructure and its history of
unresolved social conflicts the
territory of the former United States
will undergo a process of steady
degeneration punctuated by natural and
man-made cataclysms food shelter
transportation security when it comes to
supplying these survival necessities the
Soviet example offers many valuable
lessons as I already mentioned in a
collapse many economic negatives become
positives and vice versa let us consider
each one of these in turn the Soviet
agricultural sector was plagued by
inconsistent underperformance in many
ways this was the legacy of the
disastrous collectivization experiment
carried out in the 1930s which destroyed
many of the more prosperous farming
households and herded people into
collective farms collectivization
undermined the ancient village based
agricultural traditions that had made
free revolutionary russia a well-fed
place that was also the breadbasket of
western europe a great deal of further
damage was
by the introduction of industrial
agriculture the heavy farm machinery
alternately compacted and tore up the
top soil while dosing it with chemicals
depleting it and killing the biota
eventually the Soviet government had to
turn to importing grain from countries
hostile to its interests United States
and Canada and eventually expanded this
to include other foodstuffs the USSR
experienced a permanent shortage of meat
and other high-protein foods and much of
the imported grain was used to raise
livestock to try to address this problem
although it was generally possible to
survive on the foods available at the
government stores the resulting diet
would have been rather poor and so
people tried to supplement it with food
they gathered raised or caught or
purchased at farmer's markets kitchen
gardens were always common and once the
economy collapsed a lot of families took
to growing food in earnest the kitchen
gardens by themselves were never
sufficient but they made a huge
difference the year 1990 was
particularly tough when it came to
trying to score something edible I
remember one particular joke from that
period black humour was has always been
one of one of Russia's main
psychological coping mechanisms a man
walks into a food store goes to the meat
counter and sees that it is completely
empty and so he asks the butcher don't
you have any fish and the butcher
answers no here's where we don't have
any meat fish is what they don't have
over at the seafood counter
poor though it was the Soviet
distribution system never collapsed
completely in particular the deliveries
of bread continued even during the worst
of times
partly because it has always been such
an important part of the Russian diet
and partly because access to bread
symbolized the pact between the people
and the communist government enshrined
in oft-repeated
revolutionary slogans also it is
important to remember that in Russia
most people have lived within walking
distance of food shops and used public
transportation to get out to their
kitchen Gardens which were often located
in the countryside immediately
surrounding the relatively dense compact
cities this combination of factors made
for some lean times but very little
manual malnutrition and no starvation in
the United States the agricultural
system is heavily industrialized and
relies on inputs such as diesel chemical
fertilizers and pesticides and perhaps
most importantly financing in the
current financial climate the farmers
access to financing is not at all
assured the agricultural system is
efficient but only if you regard fossil
fuel energy as free in fact it is a way
to transform fossil fuel energy into
food with a bit of help from sunlight to
the tune of ten calories of fossil fuel
being embodied in every calorie that is
consumed as food the food distribution
system makes heavy use of refrigerated
diesel trucks drones for transporting
food over hundreds of miles to resupply
supermarkets the food pipeline is long
and thin and it takes only a couple of
days of interruptions for supermarket
shelves to be stripped bare many people
live in places that are not within
walking distance of stores not served by
public transportation and will be cut
off from food sources once they're no
longer able to drive
besides the supermarket chains much of
the nation's nutrition needs are being
met by an assortment of fast food joints
and convenience stores
in fact in many of the less fashionable
parts of cities and towns fast food and
convenience store food is all that is
available in the near future this trend
is likely to extend even to the more
prosperous parts of towns and suburbs
fast food outfits such as McDonald's may
have more ways to cut costs and so may
prove a bit more resilient in the face
of economic collapse than supermarket
chains but they are no substitute for
food security because they too depend on
industrial agribusiness their food
inputs such as high fructose corn syrup
genetically modified potatoes various
soy based fillers factory farmed beef
pork and chicken and so forth are
derived from oil two-thirds of which is
imported as well as fertilizers are made
from natural gas they may be able to
stay in business longer supplying food
that isn't really food but eventually
they will run out of inputs along with
the rest of the supply chain before they
do they may for a time sell burgers that
aren't really burgers like the bread
that wasn't really bread that the Soviet
government distributed in Leningrad
during the Nazi blockade
it was mostly sawdust with a bit of rye
flour added for flavor can we think of
any ways to avoid this dismal scenario
the Russian example may give us a clue
many Russian families could gauge how
fast the economy was crashing and based
on that decide how many rows of potatoes
to plant could we perhaps do something
similar there is already a healthy
gardening movement in the United States
can it be scaled up the trick is to make
small patches of farm land available for
non-mechanical cultivation by
individuals and families in increments
as small as 1,000 feet the ideal spots
would be fertile fertile bits of land
with access to rivers and streams for
irrigation provisions would have to be
made for campsites and for
transportation allowing people to
undertake seasonal migrations out to the
land to grow food during the growing
season and hauled hold the produce back
to the population centers after taking
in the harvest an even simpler approach
has been successfully used in Cuba
converting urban parking lots and other
empty bits of land to raise bed
agriculture
instead of continually trucking in
vegetables and other food it is much
easier to truck in soil compost and
mulch once a season raised highways can
be closed to traffic since there is
unlikely to be much traffic in any case
and used to catch rainwater for rent for
irrigation rooftops and balconies can be
used for hot houses hen houses and a
variety of other agricultural uses how
difficult would this be to organize well
Cubans were actually helped by their
government but the Russians managed to
do it more or less in spite of to Soviet
bureaucrats so we might be able to do it
in spite of the American ones the
government could theoretically head up
such an effort purely hypothetically
speaking of course because I see no
evidence that such an effort is being
considered for our fearless national
leaders such initiatives are too low
level if they stimulate the economy and
get the banks lending again the potatoes
will simply grow themselves all they
need to do is print some more money
right moving on to shelter again let's
look at how the Russians managed to
muddle through in the Soviet Union
people did not own their out their place
of residence everyone was assigned a
place to live which was recorded in a
person's internal passport people could
not be dislodged from their place of
residence for as long as they drew
oxygen since most people in Russia live
in cities the place of residence was
usually an apartment or a room in a
communal apartment with a shared
bathroom and kitchen
there was a permanent housing shortage
and so people often doubled up with
three generations living together the
apartments were often crowded sometimes
bored bordering on squalid if people
wanted to move they had to find somebody
else who wanted to move who would want
to exchange rooms or apartments with
them there were always long waiting
lists for apartments and children often
grew up got married and had children
before receiving a place of their own
there's a these all seem like negatives
but consider the flipside of all this
the high population density made this
living arrangement quite affordable
with several generations living together
families were on hand to help each other
grandparents provided daycare freeing up
their children's time to do other things
the apartment bills buildings were
always built near public transportation
so they did not have to rely on private
cars to get around apartment buildings
are relatively cheap to heat and
municipal services are easy to provide
and maintain because if the short runs
of pipe and cable perhaps most
importantly after the economy collapsed
people lost their savings many people
lost their jobs even those that still
had jobs often did not get paid for
months and when they were the value of
their wages was destroyed by
hyperinflation but there were no
foreclosures no evictions municipal
services such as heat water and
sometimes even hot water continued to be
provided and everyone had their families
closeby also because it was so difficult
to relocate people generally stayed in
one place for generations and so they
tended to know all the people around
them after the economic collapse there
was a large spike in the crime rate
which made it very helpful to be
surrounded by people who weren't
strangers and who could keep an eye on
things
lastly in an interesting twist the
Soviet housing arrangement delivered an
amazing final windfall in the 1990s all
of these apartments were privatized and
the people who lived in them suddenly
became owners of some very valuable real
estate free and clear switching back to
the situation in the u.s. in recent
months many people have reconciled
themselves to the idea that their house
is not an ATM machine nor is it a nest
egg they already know that they will not
be able to comfortably retire by selling
it or get rich by fixing it up and
flipping it and quite a few people have
acquiesced to the fact that real estate
prices are going to continue heading
lower the question is how much lower a
lot of people still think that there
must be a lower limit a realistic price
this thought is connected to the notion
that housing is a necessity after all
everybody needs a place to live well it
is certainly true that some sort of
shelter is necessary
be it an apartment a dorm room a bunk in
a barrack a boat a camper a tent a
teepee a wigwam a shipping container the
list is virtually endless but there is
no reason to think at all that a
suburban single-family house is in any
sense a requirement it is little more
than a cultural preference and a very
short-sighted one at that most suburban
houses are expensive to heat and cool
inaccessible by public transportation
expensive to hook up to public utilities
because of the long runs of pipe and
cable and require a great deal of
additional public expenditure on road
bridge and highway maintenance school
buses traffic enforcement and other
nonsense they often take up what was
once valuable agricultural land they
promote a car centric culture that is
destructive of urban environments
causing a proliferation of dead
downtown's many families that live in
suburban houses can no longer afford to
live in them and expect others to bail
them out as far as this living
arrangement as this living arrangement
becomes unaffordable for all concerned
it will also become unlivable
municipalities and public utilities will
not have the funds to lavish on sewer
water electricity road and bridge repair
and police without cheap and plentiful
gasoline natural gas and heating oil
many suburban dwellings will become both
inaccessible and unlivable the
inevitable result will be a mass
migration of suburban refugees toward
the more survivable more densely settled
towns and cities the luckier ones will
find friends or family to stay with for
the rest it would be very helpful to
improvise a solution one obvious answer
is to repurpose the ever plentiful
vacant office buildings for residential
use converting offices to dormitories is
quite straightforward many of them
already have kitchens and bathrooms
plenty of partitions and other furniture
and all they're really missing is beds
putting in bed is just not that
difficult the new subsistence economy is
unlikely to generate a large surplus
that is necessary for sustaining the car
and law
large population of office plankton the
businesses that once occupied these
offices are not coming back so we might
as well find new and better uses for
them another category of real estate
that is likely to go unused and that can
be repurposed for new communities is
college campuses the American four-year
college is an institution of dubious
merits it exists because American public
schools fail to teach in 12 years what
Russian public schools managed to teach
an eighth as fewer and fewer people
become able to afford college which is
likely to happen because meager career
prospects after graduation will make
them bad risks for student loans
perhaps this will provide the impetus to
do something about the public education
system one idea would be to scrap it and
then start small but eventually build
something a bit more on par with world
standards college campuses make perfect
community centers their dormitories for
newcomers fraternities and sororities
for the more subtle residents and plenty
of grand public buildings that can be
put to a variety of uses a college
campus normally contains the usual
wasteland of mowed turf that can be
repurposed to grow food or at the very
least hay and to graze cattle perhaps
some enlightened administrators trustees
and faculty members will fall upon this
idea once they see admissions flatlining
and endowments dropping to zero without
any need for government involvement so
so here we have a ray of hope don't we
moving on to transportation here we need
to make sure that people don't get
stranded in places that are not
survivable then we have to provide for
seasonal migrations to places where
people can grow catch or gather their
own food and then back to places where
they can survive the winter without
freezing to death or going stir-crazy
from cabin fever lastly some amount of
freight will have to be moved to
transport transport food to population
centers as well as enough coal and
firewood to keep the pipes from freezing
in the remaining habitable dwellings all
of this is going to be a bit of a
challenge because it all hinges on the
availability of transportation fuels and
it seems very probable that
transportation fuels will be both too
expensive and in short supply before too
long from about 2005 and until the
middle of 2008 the global oil supply has
been holding steady unable to grow
materially beyond a level that has been
characterized as a bumpy plateau an
all-time record was set in 2005 and then
after a period of record high oil prices
again only in 2008 then as the financial
collapse gathered speed oil and other
commodity prices crashed along with oil
production
more recently the oil markets have come
to rest on an altogether different bumpy
plateau the oil prices are bumping along
at around $40 a barrel and can't seem to
be able to go lower it would appear that
oil production costs have risen to a
point where it does not make economic
sense to sell oil at below this price
now $40 a barrel is a good price for US
consumers at the moment but there is
hyperinflation on the horizon thanks to
the money printing extravaganza
currently underway in Washington and 40
could easily become 400 and then 4,000 a
barrel swiftly pricing US consumers out
of the international oil market on top
of that exporting countries would balk
at the idea of trading their oil for an
increasingly worthless currency and
would start insisting on payment in kind
in some kind of tangible
export commodity which the u.s. in its
current economic state would be
hard-pressed to provide in any great
quantity domestic oil production is in
permanent decline and can provide only
about a third of current needs this is
still quite a lot of oil but it will be
very difficult to avoid the knock-on
effects of widespread oil shortages
there will be widespread hoarding quite
a lot of gasoline will simply evaporate
into the atmosphere vented from various
jerrycans and improvised storage
containers the rest will disappear into
the black market and much fuel will be
wasted driving around looking for
someone willing to part with a bit of
gas that's needed for some small but
critical mission I'm quite familiar with
this scenario because I happen to be in
Russia during a time of gasoline
shortages on one occasion I found out by
word of mouth that a certain gas station
was open and distributing ten liters of
peace I brought along my uncle's wife
who at the time was eight months
pregnant and we tried to use her huge
belly to convince the gas station
attendant to give us an extra 10 liters
with which to drive her to the hospital
when the time came no dice that that
answer was everybody's eight months
pregnant
how can you argue with such logic so 10
litres was it for us to belly or no
belly so what can we do to get our
little critical missions accomplished in
spite of chronic fuel shortages the most
obvious idea of course is to not use any
fuel bicycles carb cargo bikes in
particular are an excellent adaptation
sailboats are a good idea - not only do
they hold large amounts of cargo but
they can cover huge distances all
without the use of fossil fuels of
course they're restricted to the
coastlines and the navigable waterways
they will be hampered by the lack of
dredging due to the inevitable budget
shortfalls and by bridges that refused
to open again due to lack of maintenance
funds but here ancient maritime
techniques and improvisations can be
brought to bear to solve such problems
all very low-tech and reasonably priced
of course cars and trucks will not
disappear entirely here again some
reasonable adaptations can be brought to
bear in my book I advocated banning the
sale of new cars as was done in in the
US during World War two the benefits are
numerous first older cars are overall
more energy efficient than new cars
because of the massive amount of energy
that went into their manufacturing is
more highly amortized second large
energy savings accrue from the shutdown
of an entire industry devoted to
designing building marketing and
financing new cars third older cars
require more maintenance reinvigorating
the local economy at the expense of
mainly foreign car manufacturers and
helping reduce the trade deficit fourth
this will create a shortage of cars
translating automatically into fewer
shorter car trips higher passenger
occupancy per trip and more bicycling
and use of public transportation saving
even more energy lastly this would allow
the car to be made obsolete on about the
same time scale as the oil industry that
made it possible we'll run out of cars
[Applause]
we will run out of cars just as we run
out of gas here we are only a year or so
later and I'm most heartened to see that
the US auto industry has taken my advice
on the other hand the government's
actions continue to disappoint instead
of trying to solve problems they would
rather continue to create boondoggles
the latest one is the idea of
subsidizing sales of new cars the idea
of making cars more efficient by making
more efficient cars is sheer folly I can
take any pickup truck and increase its
fuel efficiency by one or two thousand
percent just by breaking a few laws
first you pack about a dozen people into
the bed standing shoulder-to-shoulder
like sardines second you drive about 25
miles an hour down the highway because
going any faster would waste fuel and
wouldn't be safe with so many people in
the back and so there you are per
passenger fuel efficiency increased by a
factor of 20 I believe the Mexicans have
done some extensive research in this
area with excellent results another
excellent idea pioneered in Cuba is
making it illegal not to pick up
hitchhikers cars with cars with vacant
seats are flagged down and matched up
with people who need a lift
yet another idea since passenger rail
service is in such sad sad shape and
since it is unlikely that funds will be
found to improve it why not bring back
the venerable institution of riding the
rails by requiring rail freight
companies to provide a few empty box
cars for the hobos the energy cost of
the additional weight is negligible and
the hobos don't require stops because
they can jump on and off
and only a couple of cars per train
would ever be needed because hobos as
you know are almost infinitely
compressible and they can even ride on
rooftops if needed
one final transportation idea start
breeding donkeys horses are finicky and
expensive but donkeys can be very cost
effective and make good pack animals my
grandfather had a donkey while he was
living in Tashkent and Central Asia
during World War two there was nothing
much for the donkey to eat but as a
member of the Communist Party my
grandfather had a subscription to Pravda
the Communist Party newspaper and and so
that's what the donkey ate apparently
donkeys can digest any kind of cellulose
even if when it's loaded with communist
propaganda if I had a donkey I would
feed at the Wall Street Journal
[Applause]
and so we come to the subject of
security both collapse Russia suffered
from a serious crime wave ethnic mafias
ran rampant veterans who served in
Afghanistan went into business for
themselves there were numerous contract
killings muggings murders went unsolved
left and right and in general the place
just wasn't safe Russians living in the
US would hear that I'm heading back
there for another visit and would give
me a wide-eyed stare how can I think of
doing such a thing
I came through unscathed somehow I made
a lot of interesting observations along
the way one interesting observation is
that once collapse occurs it becomes
possible to rent a policeman either for
a special occasion or generally just to
follow someone around it is even
possible to hire a soldier or two armed
with ak-47s just to help you run errands
not us not only is it possible to do
such things it is often a very good idea
especially if you happen to have
something valuable that you don't want
to part with if you can't afford their
services then you should try to be
friends with them and to be helpful to
them in various ways well there that
although their demands might seem
exorbitant at times it is still a good
idea to do all you can to keep them on
your side for instance they might at
some point insist that you and your
family move out to the garage so they
can live in your house this may be
upsetting at first but then is it really
such a good idea for you and your family
to live alone in a big house all by
yourselves
with so many armed men running around it
may make sense to station some of them
right in your own house so that they
have a base of operations from which to
maintain a watch and patrol the
neighborhood a couple of years ago I
half jokingly proposed a political
solution to collapse mitigation and
formulated a platform for the so-called
collapse party I published it with the
caveat that I didn't think there was
of a chance of my proposals becoming
part of the national agenda much to my
surprise I turned out to be wrong for
instance I propose that we stop making
cars and lo and lo and behold the auto
industry shuts down I also propose that
we start granting amnesties to prisoners
because the US has the world's largest
prison population and will not be
available to available able to afford to
keep so many people locked up it is
better to release prisoners gradually
over time rather than in a single large
general amnesty the way Saddam Hussein
did it right before the u.s. invaded and
lo and behold many states are starting
to implement my proposal
it looks like California in particular
will be forced to release some 60,000 of
270,000 people it keeps locked up this
is a good start I also propose that we
dismantle all overseas military bases
there are over a thousand of them and
repatriate all the troops and it looks
like that is starting to happen as well
except for the currently planned little
side trip to Afghanistan I also proposed
a biblical Jubilee forgiveness of all
debts public and private let's give that
one half a decade but if we look at just
that just at the changes that are
already occurring just a simple
predictable lack of funds as the federal
government and the state governments all
go broke will transform American society
in predictable ways as municipalities
run out of money police protection will
evaporate but the police still have to
eat and we'll find ways to use their
skills on a freelance basis similarly as
military bases around the world are shut
down
soldiers will soldiers will return to a
country that will be unable to
reintegrate them into civilian life
barold prisoners will find themselves
and much the same predicament and so we
will have former soldiers former police
and former prisoners a big happy family
with a few bad apples and some violent
tendencies the end result will be a
country awash with various categories of
armed men most of them unemployed and
many of them with border borderline
psychotic the police in the United
States are a troubled group many of them
lose all touch with people who are not
on the force and most of them develop an
us-versus-them mentality the soldiers
returning from a tour of duty often
suffer from post-traumatic stress
disorder the paroled prisoners suffer
from a variety of psychological ailments
as well all of them will sooner or later
realize that their problems are not
medical but rather political this will
make it impossible for society to
continue to exercise control over them
all of them will be making good use of
their weapons training and other
professional skills to acquire whatever
they need to survive and the really
important point to remember is that they
will be doing these things whether or
not anyone thinks it is legal for them
to be doing them I said this before and
I will say it again very few things are
good or bad per se everything has to be
considered within a context and in
opposed to collapse context not having
to worry whether or not something is
legal may be a very good thing in the
midst of a collapse we will not have
time to deliberate legislate interpret
set precedents and so on having to worry
about pleasing a complex and expensive
legal system it's the last thing we
should have to worry about some legal
impediments are really small and trivial
but they can be quite annoying
nevertheless a homeowner's association
might say want to give you a ticket or
seek a court order against you for not
mowing your lawn or for keeping
livestock in your garage
or or for that nice windmill you erected
on a hill that you don't own without
first getting a building permit or some
municipal busybody might try to get you
arrested for demolishing a certain
derelict bridge because it was
interfering with boat traffic you know
little things like that well if the
associate Association is aware that you
have a large number of well-armed
mentally unstable friends some of whom
still wear military and police uniforms
for old times sake
then they probably won't give you that
ticket or seek that court order or
suppose you have a great new invention
that you want to make and distribute a
new agricultural implement it's a sort
of flail studded with sharp blades it
has a hundred and one uses and is highly
cost effective and and reasonably safe
provided you don't lose your head while
using it although people have taken to
calling it the flying guillotine you
think that this is an acceptable risk
but you're concerned about the issues of
consumer safety and liability insurance
and possibly even criminal liability
once again it is very helpful to have a
large number of influential physically
impressive mildly psychotic friends who
whenever some legal matter comes up to
can just go and see the lawyers you know
have a friendly chat demonstrate the
proper use of the flying guillotine and
generally do whatever they have to do to
settle the matter amicably without any
money changing hands and without signing
any legal documents or say the
government starts being difficult about
moving things and people in and out of
the country or it wants to take too much
of a cut from commercial transactions or
perhaps your state or your town decides
to conduct its own foreign policy and
the federal government sees it fit to
interfere then it maybe may turn out to
be a good thing too if someone has
enough firepower to bring the government
or what remains of it to its senses and
convince it to be reasonable and play
nice or perhaps you want to start a
community health clinic so that you can
provide some relief
to people who would wouldn't otherwise
have any health care you don't dare call
yourself a doctor because these people
are suspicious of doctors because
doctors were always trying to rob them
of their life savings but perhaps you
have some medical training that you got
in say Cuba and you're able to handle a
cesarean or an appendectomy to suture
wounds to treat infections at bones etc
you also want to be able to distribute
opiates that your friends in Afghanistan
periodically sent to you to to ease the
pain of a hard post collapse life while
going through all of the licensing
boards and getting the certifications
and the permits and the malpractice
insurance is all completely unnecessary
provided you can surround yourself with
a lot of well-armed well-trained
mentally unstable friends food shelter
transportation security security is very
important maintaining order and public
safety requires discipline and
maintaining discipline for a lot of
people requires the threat of force this
means that people must be ready to come
to each other's defense take
responsibility for each other and do
what's right
right now security is provided by a
number of bloated bureaucratic
ineffectual institutions which inspire
more anger and despondency than
discipline and dispense not so much
violence as ill treatment that is why we
have the world's highest prison
population there supposedly there to
protect people from each other but in
reality their mission is not even to
provide security it is to safeguard
property and those who own it once these
institutions run out of resources there
will be a period of upheaval but in the
end people will be forced to learn to
deal with each other face to face and
justice will will once again become a
personal virtue rather than a federal
department I've covered what I think are
the basics based on what I saw work and
what I think might work reasonably well
here I assume that a lot of you are
thinking that this is all quite far into
the future if in fact it ever gets that
bad you should certainly feel free to
think that way the danger there is that
you will miss the opportunity to adapt
to the new
ahead of time and then you will get
trapped as I see it there is a choice to
be made you can accept the failure of
the system now and change your course
accordingly or you can decide that you
must try and stay the course and then
you will probably have to accept your
own individual failure later so how do
you prepare lately I've been hearing
from a lot of high-powered successful
people about their various high-powered
successful associates usually the story
goes something like this my a financial
adviser or be my investment banker or
see Mike and a commanding officer has
recently a foot all his money in gold or
be bought a log cabin up in the
mountains or sea built a bunker on under
his house stocked with six months of
food and water
is this normal and I tell them yes of
course it's perfectly harmless he's just
having a mid collapse crisis but that's
not really preparation that's just
someone being colorful in an offbeat
countercultural sort of way so how do
you really prepare well let's go through
a list of questions that people
typically ask me and I will try to
briefly respond to each one okay first
question how about all these financial
boondoggles what on earth is going on
people are losing their jobs left and
right and if we calculate unemployment
the way it was done during the Great
Depression instead of looking at the cup
numbers the government is trying to feed
us now then we're heading toward 20%
unemployment and is there any reason to
think it'll stop there do you happen to
believe that prosperity is around the
corner
not only jaws and housing equity but
retirement savings are also evaporating
the federal government's our stroke
state government to stroke some more
than others and the best they can do is
print more money which will quickly lose
value so how can we get the basics if we
don't have any money how is that done
good question as I briefly mentioned the
basics of food shelter transportation
and security
let's focus on shelter shelter poses a
particularly interesting interesting
problem at the moment it is still very
much overpriced with many people paying
mortgages and rents that they can no
longer afford while numerous properties
stand fecund the solution of course is
to cut your losses and stop paying but
then you might have soon have to
relocate this is okay because as I
mentioned there's no shortage of vacant
properties around finding a good place
to live will become less and less of a
problem as people stop paying their
rents and mortgages and get foreclosed
or evicted because the number of vacant
properties will only increase the best
course of action is to become a property
caretaker legitimately occupying a
vacant property rent-free and keeping an
eye on things for the owner what if you
can't find a position as a property
caretaker well you might have to become
a squatter or maintain a list of vacant
properties while keeping your camping
gear handy if you do get tossed out
chances are the people who tossed you
out will will then think of hiring a
property caretaker to keep the squatters
out and what do you do if you become a
property caretaker well you take care of
the property of course but you also look
out for all of the other squatters
because they are the reason you have a
legitimate place to live a squatter in
hand is worth three absentee landlords
in the bush the absentee landlord might
eventually cut his losses too and go
away but your squatter friends will
remain as your neighbors having some
neighbors is much better than living in
a ghost town what if you still have a
job how do you prepare them the obvious
answer is be prepared to quit or to be
laid off or fired at any moment it
really doesn't matter which one of these
it turns out to be the point is to
sustain zero psychological damage in the
process get your burn rate to as close
to zero as you can by spending as little
money as possible so that when the job
goes away not much has to change while
at work do as little as possible because
all this economic activity is just a
terrible burden
environment gently ride it to a stop and
jump off if you still have a job or if
you still have some savings what do you
do with all the money the obvious answer
is build up inventory the money will be
worthless but a box of bronze nails will
still be a box of bronze nails buy and
stock file useful stuff especially stuff
that can be used to create various kinds
of alternative systems for growing food
providing shelter and providing
transportation and security thank you if
you don't own a patch of dirt free and
clear where you can put it where you can
stockpile stuff then you can rent a
storage container pay it a few years
forward and just sit on it and until
reality kicks in again and there's
something useful for you to do with it
some of you may be frightened by the
future I just described and rightly so
there is nothing any of us can do to
change the path we're on it is a huge
huge system with tremendous inertia and
trying to change its path is like trying
to change the path of a hurricane what
we can do is prepare ourselves and each
other mostly by changing our
expectations our preferences and scaling
down our needs it may mean that you will
miss out on some last uncertain bit of
enjoyment on the other hand by
refashioning yourself into someone who
might stand a better chance of adapting
to the new circumstances you will be
able to give to yourself and to others a
great deal of hope that would otherwise
not exist thank you
the questions what I was so rattled by
that I dropped all the questions the
questions will be in random order then
really weird probably in random order
before somebody won't give their name
says do you get invited to cocktail
parties yes yes actually yeah I do get
invited to cocktail parties here's an
interesting question for Robin Sloane
over here in my post collapse
neighborhood how am I going to keep tabs
on what is going on how does media
change this TV work about the Internet
should I be keeping a printing press in
my basement media was not one of the
four things you mentioned yeah that's a
that's a really good question I think
that we have enough technology that we
can plug together in various interesting
ways my favorite example of just a
complete you know throwback to the 70s
and the 70s there was fidonet in in
rural Maine that relied on ham radios
and I think something like 2400 baud
modems all kind of patched together with
Atari on trs-80 computers used to
exchange mail email at the time and that
worked pretty well so I think that if a
few people you know they're enough
engineers around so if we have some
equipment sitting around some some solar
panels you know some some radio
equipment etc we'll probably patch
something together somehow well it's
interesting that I've been looking at
squatter cities in the world where a
billion people live the way you've just
described and one of the things that's
doing very well there are cell phones
and one of the reasons they're doing
well there as well as elsewhere is it's
a fairly bottom-up entrepreneurial world
where you know the guy gets a few
handsets and self son built a tower and
then from that get sells more handsets
appreciating running power and it's a
kind of a ground-up infrastructure which
is a media form
I think that's likely to survive into
these circumstances I'm not sure the
older the equipment the longer it lasts
that that seems to me take the case like
the
you know the newer stuff seems to be a
lot more fragile the technology gets
more complicated over time like really
old equipment you can fix just by
soldering new chips and new equipment
forget it you'll love some of the slides
by on chip Chase who shows streets in
Delhi and Mumbai and so on we're in the
slums square they have
reverse-engineered all the cell phones
in the world the handsets and so the
ones that we throw away wind up there
and there are local manuals in the local
language where they figured out how to
fix these things basically forever it's
like cars and Cuba mm-hmm and it's so
valuable to everybody in terms of this
kind of grassroots economy they're
talking about that that actually does
pretty well there and and it's something
that wasn't in Russia in the 90s I'm
curious how cell phones are doing in
Russia now extremely well yeah yeah the
cell phone coverage there is quite
impressive but I think there will be
enough electronic junk left over for us
to communicate non not face-to-face I
think the challenge is getting enough
people talking to each other
face-to-face and not depending on
technology Alexander Rose has a question
how many citizens in Russia had firearms
forthe collapse in the US there are more
guns than people and will that make it
different I mean this is not a question
just of lots of guys that formerly in
prison or in the police and the military
would that attitudes and weapons but a
lot of people who were none of those who
also have weapons how does that change I
think you know the NGO the gun culture
here is you know a big part of it and I
think you know there will be a lot of
bullet holes and various things things
people so I think that will be
unfortunate you know a lot of a lot of
stuff will get strafed and you know I
see that happening I think that that's
going to be a part of it
tomorrow Spaulding is where over here
thank you
as there are large cultural is there a
larger racial and cultural diversity in
America than Russia do you think the
more recent American culture will reach
different respond differently and more
as using in a sense more hybrid vigor
than might have been the case with the
fairly historically embedded culture in
Russia well Russia is an interesting
country because it you know it's called
Russia well actually it's called Russian
Federation for good reason because
Russians are an ethnic minority it'll be
a majority Muslim country before too
long but it's a very inclusive ethnicity
people who speak Russian call themselves
Russian and and they call themselves
Russian something else you know Russian
Korean Russian Jew Russian whatever and
so that that sort of the the ethnic
identity it's a it's a very mongrel
identity and and I think that that helps
the the this saner more stable parts of
Russia because there isn't really an
exclusive identity and the places that
turned out to be the most fragile were
the ones that had some you know
newfangled nationalism for a country of
you know twenty thousand people you know
claimed some exclusive right to a piece
of turf and you know that generate
degenerated into ethnic cleansing and
that sort of happened more more in the
perimeter than in the center the other
thing that happened in Russia that will
probably happen here is ethnic mafias
had a big role to play
you know the Chechens in particular but
a few other ethnic groups as well
basically seized certain parts of the
the new business they had a new free
enterprise business so for a while there
in Russia you could buy a lot of stuff
from little kiosks little metal locked
booths where you would shove your
gigantic roll of worthless money through
a hole and they would shove back a
bottle of vodka you know whatever you
wanted those were all run by the Chechen
mafia and
because nobody could understand what
they're saying to each other they had a
secret code so because nobody speaks
judgin except Chechens so you know they
had they had the ability to thrive in
that environment and that caused a lot
of problems here's question from Ken
Wilson and I think over here
fertility collapsed in Russia was this
an adaptation or a vulnerability how
quickly will the u.s. population change
how might we prepare for that well I
mean I think Russian fertility is sort
of a you know a case in point that that
issue just keep killing people
generation after generation they stopped
breeding that well after a while I mean
Russia lost so many men and you know
during the revolution you know during
the civil war afterwards during World
War two during the various Stalinist
repressions etc was a very disrupted
society and the other thing is that you
know everybody was short of living space
so if you had more than two children you
had to stack them vertically you know
somehow there was no room for to spread
them out so you know people were very
much hemmed in by their you know the
environment and their living situation
the fact that you know Russia has a
smaller population now I don't know
whether it's a you know a plus or a
minus because you know a smaller
population is certainly easier to feed
given the same amount of land but right
now
well Putin put a put some measures into
place so mothers get ten thousand
dollars for for having a child now just
think they've gotten quite up to the the
France bribe yet yeah they're working on
it last I heard Russia had a birth rate
of 1.2 children for a woman yeah well it
was an extinction three generations yeah
and you know it's quite possible that
that will happen or it's quite possible
that it won't it's it's really hard to
see but you know that that's sort of the
result of the enormous die offs that
occurred throughout the 20th century so
Ken's question was do you think any of
that maps to here is this just a
completely different story here I think
it's a completely different story
okay I mean to give you an example the
United States lost fewer men in all of
World War two than my hometown in Russia
thank you that's a reminder all this
worth making
looks like flank revi is that a real
name I'm gonna ask it a little more
though because he's saying your first
for post collapse government priorities
of food transportation shelter and
security yes what about energy and I
would put in terms what about great
energy which is not an oil question it's
a coal question a nuclear various other
things this great energy go away or was
that for example kept up in Russia it
was kept up in Russia I think it was
built a little better in Russia Russians
had this engineering culture that caused
them to over-design things in ridiculous
ways and electrification was one of the
things that they over designed
ridiculously I mean you can go to Russia
and look at gigantic concrete
transformer buildings where here it
would be just a bunch of exposed
transformer sitting behind some
chain-link fence and there it's an
edifice and and so that that all held
together pretty well and amazingly
except for for Chernobyl and maybe a few
other radiation leaks they you know the
nuclear energy sector held together
reasonably well and they managed to
retrofit it for safety and have been
keeping it running that they finally put
containment vessels on the reactors or
they still I'm not sure I think in some
cases they have Kim and Kelly says other
empires have collapsed without
individual hardship you forecast
forecasts for the former USA the British
and ottoman empire's sank without social
upheaval at home do you have any other
scenarios for the breakup of the US
reduce military power but without hobos
jeepneys donkeys in one way crime do you
have any other versions of a gentler
kinder gentler collapse well no because
the the the Empire's that collapse
gently I think didn't have to
drastically change their cultures and
their ways of living I think you know
the Turks still just walk to market to
buy vegetables you know they they didn't
have to give up an entire you know way
of way of life
here's a trick question from Tom
Hetherington after the collapse of the
USSR Russia became capitalist and more
like the USA so isn't Russia headed for
another collapse just like us I think
Russia has if had it for collapse it
will be a slightly different one now
people think that these Western labels
what can can be applied to to Russia
more or less directly that you know if
you're talking about Russian democracy
that would be like democracy somewhere
else the fact it probably just means
that the Communists get elected again
because they're popular same thing with
capitalism
you know Russian capitalism is not what
you'd think capitalism should be it's
what Russians think capitalism should be
so it's basically a state system was you
know big monopolies government
monopolies monopolies that in other
places would be called you know state
champions or something like that and
then the money that they accumulate
trickles down through or the rest of the
economy in good times it's more of a
flood than a trickle actually but that's
how the entire economy structured it's
it's nothing like what capitalism is
here and in terms of financial collapse
I guess they learn some lessons but not
others from the experience in the 90s
because at the start of the crisis
Russia had fourth largest foreign
reserves in the world of any country in
the world loss of gold reserves they had
a gigantic Stabilization Fund that they
could just burn through and it's not
working that well and there are a lot of
complaints about how it's not working
that well but they started from
financial strengths not financial
weakness they didn't have the equivalent
of China
backing up their apparatus well they
basically started trying to support the
currency I don't think if that if that
worked particularly well the the biggest
problem for them is that the flow of
money from abroad in exchange for
commodities has slowed down because of
the crash and commodity prices question
for Michael M who is best prepared for
this in America today it's a multiple
choice question the mafia the militias
burning men illegal immigrants or the
super wealthy I think for the rural poor
the ones that actually have some kind of
a subsistence economy are the ones that
probably could go on the longest without
noticing that any big changes have
occurred because being poor takes a lot
of practice and and if you've had
practice upfront then once you are
forced to be poor then it's not that big
a change
I think the Amish are fairly well
prepared I think those those would be
the two groups
being poor takes lots of practices a
take-home line
mmm-hmm interestingly specifics on these
guy I can't resist passing on and that's
where you want to answer John Perry
Barlow right here comes to us from
Wyoming since we'll be stockpiling
ammunition for our future well armed the
turf friends of what calibers will they
prefer my preference would be for you
know an SKS or an ak-47 they take the
same ammo which you can buy at any
market anywhere in the world seven six
two or something yeah so that's like the
obvious thing and the SKS is enough for
you know most things and and then
shotguns but don't bother with handguns
I'll go to a gun fight with a knife bob
cut POC I think it is says aren't
well-armed psychopaths more skittish and
hard to train and control than horses
my wife is bringing up because he deals
with horses and you know it's a close
call
well well I guess to be fair you have to
compare them to psychopathic horses but
they're all well-armed look you live on
a sailboat right yes and these many
people here how many saw that bay tree
was in a New Yorker piece a week or two
ago a few here and you were grouped with
Nassim Taleb and and with the suburb
Peter what's his name yeah say a little
more about how you got on this the other
boat sailboat what you're learning
living in preparation for the collapse
that you see and what's sort of the
sequence the narrative the arc of that
process for you
yeah well Ben McGrath who wrote The New
Yorker article called what I'm doing
bourgeois survivalism
and I thought that it's it's strange
funny but I think he has my number
because you know basically I was living
with my wife in a condo in in Boston and
I was watching what was going on and you
know in in the economy and and so I
decided that now is the time to sell and
did this was when this was
two-and-a-half years ago and and so I
pocketed a whole bunch of money from
that and the reason I did that was
because I wanted to do with the money in
in inventory or in gold I won't tell you
okay that's why but anyway the reason we
moved on to the boat was it was because
I wanted to do other things I didn't
really want to just work day jobs
forever and I wanted to take a year off
so moving on to both was a very good way
to do it so we moved on to the boat and
then we sailed off and sailed the entire
eastern seaboard seaboard from from
Maine to Florida and back you know had a
lot of interesting experiences and then
arrived back in Boston where you know
we're living at Constitution marina was
just very nice a rent this winter is 400
a month and and I have a 15 minute walk
to a skyscraper where I have a job so
it's sort of where's why survivalism you
know it's sort of like okay well I could
I could spend all my money on a place to
live or I could just like you know save
it all and and live within 15 minutes of
work and it just makes sense you know
the downside is that it's a bit cramped
and things get moldy very easily and you
know it when there's a storm you know
there's a lot of emotion you know a few
things like that but in general I I
think I you know I like living on a boat
well enough that I would like to
continue doing that and in the process
I've learned all about maintaining a
sailboat which is for me you know
probably the more interesting part
because sailing is actually quite
boring you know get out there you set it
on the word and it goes until the wind
changes so yeah so that's basically my
experience well this is one advantage
many of the cities around coasts and you
know water may be rising but if you live
in a place that floats you don't care my
wife and I live in a tugboat we've lived
on for 25 years and it's all the things
you say but we've been there for 25
years because it's actually pretty neat
and is the marina you're in have other
people in the boats are you kind of one
of the loans inhabitants there's over a
hundred people who all belong to a
newsgroup
a yahoo news group and they're always
getting together and drinking beer and
drama and singing karaoke and you know
swimming around in the swimming pool
whatever else it's it's like it's a wild
social scene there's a party whenever
anyone shows up pretty much and there's
over a hundred of them very gregarious
well there's another thing that we see
on the houseboat area Sausalito is the
one advantage of a relatively stable
relatively dense community is it
actually is a community and a lot of
security of various sorts goes with that
even without weapons and it's also a
nice way to live well actually this is
you know from this perspective collapse
looks like a interesting neighborhood
revival event
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you